I'm containing stone Oh Nicolo here's
the situation you've got a very odd
approach because you claim you want a
Labour government but you're saying
anyone but labour in England you're
saying vote green in Wales you're saying
vote like uh Murray and of course in
Scotland you're saying vote SNP and you
know that for every one less Labour MP
the likelihood is that we'll end up with
David Cameron and Nick Clegg not on the
stage tonight perhaps with a bit of net
net Nigel thrown in and the truth is you
want to gamble on getting rid of a Tory
government I can guarantee that we get
rid of a Tory government if you vote
Labour in this election and the reality
is this if on me they eat there are more
anti Tory MPs in the House of Commons
than there are Tory MPs then if we work
together we can lock David Cameron out
of Downing Street
so tell me tonight a lot is it the case
that you would rather see David Cameron
go back into Downing Street than what
was the SNP know the feeling
no the difference is Nicola I fought
Tories all my life unlike the SNP which
presses a Tory government in 1979 unlike
your leader Alex Salmond who said Boat
Lib Dem in 2010 and we end up with a Lib
Dem Tori : done like you at this
election sevens unit for labour all your
toys they're gone I got this cake David
Cameron alright obtaining street-door
Tanya barren I think he ever forget you
alright